it is an absolute Hive of activity
preparing Mass graves because they
simply can't cope with the number of
dead that they've suffered not only in
country that goes into the thousands
but also those that are being brought
over from turkey and other Mass grave
there
so many syrians fled over the border to
Turkey to safety what they thought was
safety from the war here because
remember this is a country that is still
very much at War
there are sanctions against it the
people here are complaining that they're
not getting any Aid through and if there
is any it is very very small so small is
to make hardly any difference whatsoever
they've had to cope with this Mass
natural disaster themselves completely
themselves and this is the scene every
day so far since the earthquake happened
well meanwhile Syrian president Bashar
al-assad made his first public
appearance since the Quakes visiting the
Watson city of Aleppo as the world food
program called for more Aid to be
allowed across the border he used his
visit to criticize the West
they're saying that the West is
prioritizing politics over the
humanitarian situation but that's not
true to give priority to one over the
other both situations the humanitarian
and the political have to exist in the
west only the political situation exists
not the humanitarian the politicization
of the situation that's normal for the
humanitarian conditions don't exist
either today or in the past
and Syrian State media says the
government has approved the delivery of
Aid to rebel-held areas these are the
latest pictures of 14 una trucks heading
towards those Rebel head air rebel-held
areas in the northwest of Syria
officials say the Convoy includes tents
blankets hygiene products and food for
survivors of the quake